Francis Wayne author of Karl Marx a life
what led to your interest in this man
will I was beaten reasonably interested
in cow box but I suppose what really
fired it was the assumption in the early
1990s that he was now not worth
bothering with at the end of the Cold
War after the fall of the Berlin Wall
all that some end of history stuff we
got all that great helium argument from
Fukuyama the assumption was that he was
now dead and buried under the rubble of
the Berlin Wall I thought on the other
hand this was the ideal moment to dig
him up because he'd been buried long
before under all those awful Stalinist
monoliths that were created in his honor
and that he hadn't had much of a look in
for a long time and now that all that
had gone we might be able to get back to
Marx himself rather than the kind of
caricature or the icon or whatever that
he'd become where is he from originally
from Germany from the Rhineland place
called Trier and his parents were Jewish
his mother was Dutch in fact but have
moved to Germany and both his parents
came from a very long line of rabbis
Marx's uncle was a Jew is there was a
rabbi his grandfather was a rabbi and so
on but just before Marx was born his
father converted to Christianity mainly
a marriage of convenience because as a
Jew he was kind of second-class citizen
and not allowed practice in the
professions and he wanted to be a lawyer
so the father then became a Lutheran
Christian so by the time Marx was born
his father was technically a Christian
so Marx himself was sort of a Jew but
then again sort of not and sort of a
Christian but then again not ready
because his father wasn't actually a
practicing Christian any more than he'd
been a practicing Jew so he was some
from the outset I was slightly at one
removed from society when they were
respectable middle-class family his
father was quite wealthy he and
vineyards Mosel vineyards and things and
they when he could practice as a lawyer
he made even more money they moved into
a rather large house but at the same
time although they were respected for
middle-class citizens because of the
Jewish background and the anti-jewish
laws at the time he was
was slightly an outsider which I suppose
may explain why he was so interested in
ideas of alienation and estrangement
because he did feel alienated from an
early age he didn't feel part of this
society that he lived in intro here's a
is it a photograph wasn't painting in
the 1860 marks that one is painting I
believe Alto where was he in 1860 1860
he was in London he stayed in London for
most of his life not just his adult life
for most of his life he moved to London
at the end of the 1840s having been
thrown out of most of the countries in
Western Europe and he was buffeted
around he left Germany renounced his
German citizenship when he moved to
Paris in 1844 decided that Germany had
nothing more to offer him then he got
thrown out of Paris went back to went to
Belgium for a while got chucked out of
there he went back to Germany at the
time of the 1848 revolutions then he was
thrown out of Germany he ran a newspaper
there briefly that was closed down by
the authorities he was expelled again
went to Paris got expelled and ended up
in London which was the last place
willing to take political refugees and
so it was full of them I mean Italians
Matt seen he lived in London quite a
while Germans French they all tended to
fetch up in England this sort of
revolutionary flotsam and jetsam because
it was the only sanctuary left so he as
I say he went there at the end of the
eighteen forties after the failure of
the 1848 revolutions turned up in 18-49
and stayed that he died in 1883 so he
was in England for 34 years never became
remotely English in any way he didn't
really mix very much with English with a
few exceptions
he saw far more of his fellow German
exiled and French exhales but I suppose
he was literally um an alien he was a
stateless person from 1844 onwards so
from the age of 26 he had no States no
passport was the kind of embodiment of
alienation quite literally what year did
you start on the book well about three
years ago I think was when I first
decided I wanted to do it and it was
sparked partly in a spirit of perversity
it's
mr. an accident that I didn't I suppose
because my publisher in London was
badgering me to write a book for her and
I was trying to fend her off and
eventually I said to her the only book I
want to write at the moment is a life of
Karl Marx and I assumed that she would
reel back screaming and they'd say no no
no most unpopular unfashionable subject
on earth and instead she was very keen
and said great right do it as soon can
do get on with it
so I was I was quite pleased because I
did want to do it on the other hand I
was surprised because I thought no one
was interested in Marx any more but it
was a great challenge I thought this is
great I can dig the old buy up and
perhaps persuade people that he's worth
taking interest in that he is whether
you agree with him or not a serious and
major figure and also a an interesting
and human figure I mean full of human
failings is is everyday life full of
disasters and tragedies as well as a
fair amount of comedy where is this
picture taken that's in Highgate
Cemetery in North London where he
fetched up where he was buried along
with his wife and housekeeper and one of
his children
and there is that such a great rather
grim monument that was put up that's not
the original burial place he was
originally buried at the other end of
Highgate Cemetery in a rather obscure
unconsecrated corner and then in the
1940s the British Communist Party
decided they wanted to move him to a
more prominent bit at the cemetery and
build this great to bust this monument
because visiting communists quite often
wanted to go and see it and there was
nothing to see that wasn't even a
gravestone in those days and I found in
the public record office in London lots
of home office files just on the subject
of moving Marx's tomb moving his coffin
and all these senior civil servants were
saying well it must be done at the dead
of night because otherwise it could
provoke some sort of disturbance so it
was only allowed to be done on condition
that they moved the grave at I think
three o'clock in the morning because
they thought otherwise there might be
riots and demonstrations against it in
fact I don't think anyone noticed but
anyway then it was moved to where it is
now near the entrance with that enormous
great thing where for years and years of
any visitor from the Soviet Union or
indeed North Korea or China would be
obliged to go and have that picture
taken and to this day you still see them
visiting tourists making the pill
which the few remaining Marxists left in
the world we imagined before we started
you you met a man at that gravesite that
I have met just by riding the train up
to New York and what was that what were
the circumstances
well he's yes he is one of the few
surviving American Marxists he's a very
great guy called Ike Nahum and i met him
a few years ago when i started working
on the book I went to Trier to marks his
birthplace the house where he was born
which is now a museum and almost the
only other person there was this
American and we kept bumping into each
other in the various rooms and after a
while he turned to me and introduced
himself and said well I think we've seen
all this why don't we go for a drink so
we then spent the rest of the day in a
bar having a very long conversation
about all sorts of things
and he turned out to be there's some
veteran Marxists trade unionists from
New York who is an engineer on Amtrak on
the railroad and a fantastically well
read one as well I mean he'd read all 50
volumes of the collective works of Marx
and Engels as far as having read you
know all sorts of other things he's a
great tumbler autodidact he's currently
working his way through every book ever
written on the American Civil War I
think and um he I was surprised to learn
that there was anyone left in America
who would actually own up to being a
Marxist that there are a few of them
scattered about and actually when he
just announced himself to me once where
he drives those trains up to New York
you know riding on the trains that he
was a viewer but also one of the last
Marxist around what would it mean to be
one of the last Marx's what would you
believe in if you were a Marxist but
it's very hard to say because I think I
mean I tend not to use the word Marxist
if I can help it
mainly because it's become almost
meaningless because there are 57
varieties of Marxism from Stalinism to
Trotskyism to maoism Marxism Leninism
and so on and so on and I think it's
become so broad as to be almost
meaningless if someone says I mean that
Ike says he's a Marxist but who then
when someone says that have to spend
several hours discovering precisely what
they mean by it so I tend to avoid the
word and I also think it's been slightly
debased by the attachments it's gained
now in Marx himself
I think guess this was coming even in
his lifetime there was a French
political party
which he didn't approve of and they got
in touch with him and said mr. Marx
you'll be delighted to hear that we now
call ourselves a Marxist party and he
said well in that case I at least not a
Marxist so I think even before he died
he was aware that some disciples
self-styled disciples might be the bane
of his life and certainly of his death
because then of course after his death
in the 20th century you had any number
of people appointing themselves as his
spokesperson if you like from Stalin to
Kim il-sung to whoever and each of them
claimed to be the true keeper of the
faith and they can't all have been
telling the truth and I suspect that
none of them was because actually if you
look at Marx his general approach to
life and its attitudes it's hard to
believe that he would have had much time
for any of them I mean certainly in the
Soviet Union given that Marx was just
congenitally argumentative critical of
everything the Soviet Union where
argument and criticism were not really
encouraged he would have lasted about
five minutes before they threw him into
the gulag as I think I have here a
little tiny book show the audience what
it looks like and it's quite simply
stated the Communist Manifesto and
actually if you took out all of the the
different forwards for the different
editions it wouldn't be as big as it is
as you can see it's tiny what impact did
the Communist Manifesto have on the
world discussion well I think it's had a
huge impact I'm going to think you could
reasonably say it's one of the most it's
not the most influential political
pamphlet in history and it is just a
pamphlet which is one of its strengths
it's very readable very short you can
read the thing in half an hour
and it's written in fairly lively
accessible language vigorous
pamphleteering is not obscure and
impenetrable as some people accused s
capital of being I mean this is
something anyone can read so even people
who've never read anything else by Marx
quite often turn out to have read that
at some stage and it is a very lively
piece of work I think it holds up very
well and it's also surprisingly
contemporary and modern when you read it
now with 21st century eyes it's full of
stuff there which reads like an exact
description of what's going on in the
world about what would now be called
globalization I mean the same people who
tend to dismiss Marx and say here's
nothing of interest to tell us now
as often as not on the same sort of
wizkid modernized pundits who talk about
the third way and say yeah globalization
that's the thing you read the Communist
Manifesto and it's actually full of
globalization all about how the
increasing pace of communications and
developments in technology will create
this global market which will tend to be
dominated by the dominant economic
forces and you have a world where
blaming a couple years ago I was in
China in Beijing which is the capital of
a supposedly communist state market
Leninist I think it's called these days
and they are in Beijing you walk down
the street you see McDonald's Kentucky
Fried Chicken Pizza Hut Chase Manhattan
and so on
and even the hotel where I was staying
which was quite a cheap hotel it wasn't
a very grand place because I was paying
my own way even this cheap hotel in
Beijing there on the desk was a computer
and there on the screen was Microsoft
Windows so even the heart of the
supposedly communist world is no getting
away from Bill Gates at all ceremonials
are in one of marks as many other points
was the tendency of capitalism towards
monopoly left to itself know that on the
whole is spiteful to talk about
competition in the market that the
dominant figures in that market would
tend to try to squeeze out the other
competition and create a monopoly for
themselves but in natural none Sanibel
and lo and behold is their official the
US courts of degree that this is the
case with the best known capitalists of
them although Bill Gates again what year
was he born 1818 what year did he die
1883 and how many times he did marry he
married only once he married a beautiful
Prussian aristocrat called Jenny von
Westphalen her father was a baron she
was also descended from Scottish
aristocracy the Dukes of Argyll the
Earl's of Argyll
so very grand upper-class fairness which
were that she is yes and she was the
belle of the ball in Trier you know the
princess of the town had lots of suitors
but marks all marks his father and her
father became friends they were quite
near neighbours so Marx knew her from
very early youth I mean he was a baby
when he first met his future wife and
she was actually a friend of his older
sister
so he knew her all his life really and
they fell in love and she abandoned her
fiance who was a know an army officer
suitable fiance and threw in her lot
with Karl Marx and thereby condemned
herself to a life of tremendous poverty
and grind and disaster and tragedy in
exile and so on and I mean she was
depressed for a lot of the time during
their marriage as well she might have
been but at the same time she was
intensely devoted to him and fiercely
loyal I mean really tigerish ly
protective she never suggested that she
would have done anything else had she
known what they're in store and if
anyone was ever rude about her husband
or criticized him she would defend him
even more vigorously than he would
defend himself which is saying something
how many children did they have ha well
it depends how you define children
because there was an extra child out of
wedlock who was born to the housekeeper
Helen DeMuth one of the more amazing
aspects of the marks story because they
were living at the time in two rooms in
Soho in the center of London with this
some rather large household of husband
wife children housekeeper all crammed
into the two rooms but there was a brief
period where his wife Jenny went off to
Holland try and get some money out of an
uncle at one of marks his uncle's and
during this period amazing enough nine
months later the housekeeper gives birth
to a boy Freddie this is this is Jenny
on the screen right now up here in the
top this is some but as Marx his wife oh
yes there she is yes that's Jenny yes
and right below that is the housekeeper
is the housekeeper
yes that's Helen the mother of little
Freddie and this boy Freddie was given
away for adoption to her family in the
East End of London and there was what
can only be described as a cover-up I
think I say in the book the first one of
the more successful cover-ups organized
for the good of the Communist cause Marx
was aware that his enemies would use
this against him if it got out angles
stepped into the breach and pretended
that he was the father and the baby was
then given away for adoption anyway and
lived for the rest of his life he didn't
die till 1929 this illegitimate son
unaware that his real father was the man
who bothered by then
lion was you know notorious all over the
world so there was this extra child
Freddy who had I mean it's not Fox's
finest hour
and there are many moments there not his
finest hour but certainly the business
of impregnating Helen DeMuth and then
giving the child away I did think
reflect very well on the other hand it's
hard to see how they could have
accommodated any more children they had
quite enough trouble with their own
children three children died in infancy
and then of the others there were the
three surviving daughters I mean over
six altogether three of them died as
small children and three others Jenny
Laura and Eleanor Jenny died before her
father
Jenny Chandler jr. Jenny and the two
children who outlived him Laura and
Ellen are both committed suicide so this
this is Jenny that was sitting with her
father that's Jenny the daughter yes
it's rather confusing they're all called
Jenny and that family even one of the
grandchildren was called January Jenny
who committed suicide Laura and Ellen
are the only two children who outlived
Marx this is a photograph right here of
Laura yes and when why did she commit
suicide well it's hard to say they
basically she and her husband died when
they were in their 60s when they did it
they'd had three children in quick
succession when they married all three
died almost immediately and they then
had rather gloomy lives as bare as you
could say full of frustration they were
also I mean frankly sponges when Marx
dies
he'd been subsidized for most of his
life by angles and Laura just assumed
that this would be inherited the subsidy
and so she was forever writing to angles
and her husband Paul would write
triangles saying could you send us ten
pounds please so he found he had to
support the next generation as well
because they were too indigent to look
after themselves but I think they
reached a point where they both well as
far as one could tell they both just
decided that they were in their 60s life
had nothing more to offer them they were
weary and they decided to end it all in
a suicide pact and at their funeral in
France there was a visiting speaker who
gave a narration from the Russian
Communist Party
a man called vladimir Ilyich Lenin
not enough which is the only sort of
direct line edge one can trace between
Marx himself and the Soviet communists
whether he had been there while
representing the Russian communists
because this was the funeral of the
daughter of Karl Marx the Russian
Communist Party wanted to send a
representative to the funeral to make a
little speech and then in was the man
who got it what about Eleanor which she
also Helen there was a much sadder tale
much much sadder tale Ellender as you
can see from the picture very attractive
bright lively girl but had a lot of
troubles partly marks his fault yet
again you have to say because Marx had
two French sons in Lourdes his daughter
Jenny and Laura both married French
socialists marks on the whole not very
well disposed towards French socialists
he was always arguing with them
quarreling actually thought they were
Hana kists and then Eleanor fell in love
with a man called mr. Gary another
dashing French revolutionary a Marx put
his foot down he said I don't gonna have
three of my daughter's married to French
socialists I can't stand them so he more
or less forbad this Union he wouldn't
bet Eleanor see her lover and she was
ordered to break it off and she never
really recovered from this and she she
was ill for a long time she had a kind
of anorexic stage where she wouldn't eat
for long piers and then she took up with
the most unsuitable and ghastly man
called Edward Aveling
who was tremendously ugly but very
successful with women he used to say if
I have a half hours head start I could
have any woman in London and um he
somehow obviously had some sort of
magnetic appeal though certainly a lot
of people who knew him found him not
only physically disgusting but
disgusting in character he was a vile
person who treated Ellender terribly he
got secretly married while supposedly
living with Eleanor they lived together
unmarried but as most of their friends
were Bohemians this was sort of
acceptable and she then discovered that
he had secretly a year earlier got
married to somebody else without telling
her and he'd been maintaining these two
households a wife on the side was kind
of reversed the usual thing we have the
mistress on the side in his case he was
living with a mistress but also kept a
secret wife tucked away
Elna was distraught and he then agreed
that he behaved very badly and he's
we'll look let's end it all let's have
the suicide pact so they got some PRASA
Cassatt and the idea was that they were
going to die together tragically and
then he failed to keep his path the
bargain Ellen that took the plastic
asses and dies and he didn't he just
left the house and carried on as if I
think it happened I think he was very
lucky not to be charged with
manslaughter so quite frankly since he
had clearly killed her in any meaningful
sense of the phrase but that was the end
of poor Elmer it's a terrible tragic
tale especially because she had so much
to offer she was very bright talented
actress translator writer had lots of
friends Bernard Shaw was a great friend
of hers she met him in the British
Museum and she was a good speaker she
was politically very active from in the
East End of London and places but died
of a broken heart essentially you said
that he just lived a couple of miles
from Charles Darwin well a few miles yes
Marx lived in London Darwin lived down
in Kent it's more than a couple of miles
but not very far away and it is quite
striking that I suppose you'd have to
say the two most the two 19th century
thinkers who were most influential in
the 20th century probably were Marx and
Darwin in their different ways and there
they were living quite near each other
and so there has been a temptation to
try and link them in some way and there
is one slight think which is that mark
sent Darwin a copy of Das Kapital and
Darwin sent him back a polite thank-you
letter saying dear dr. Marx thank you so
much for your fascinating book the Marx
is quite excited thought the Darwin
really had read it and had marred it and
if you go because they'll find it today
if you go to Darwin's house at down in
Kent there on the bookshelves is the
copy that Marx sent him and you open it
and only about the first hundred pages
have actually been cut out of the eight
hundred pages let's clear the Darwin
just cut the first few pages glanced at
them his German wasn't that good anyway
and I'm sent the polite letter so I
didn't think he was a great fan of
Marx's what year was the Communist
Manifesto 1848 issued an ending of 1848
February 1848 in 1848 he lived where he
was well at that stage he was in Belgium
when he wrote the Communist Manifesto in
Brussels but he was on the move was
about to be on the move again because
1848 was of course one of the big years
of
Lucian's when most of Europe had
revolutions of one kind or another with
the exception of Britain time in France
Italy Germany there were revolutions all
over the place they didn't last ever
they were followed immediately by
counter-revolutions but for a brief
period there were these uprisings it was
one of those historic years and so Marx
wanted to be in the thick of it so he
moved on
he spent large part of 1848 in Germany
because that was where he wanted to be
in Cologne running a newspaper fomenting
revolution he also has been quite a bit
of time in France he was invited back to
France by the provisional government the
revolutionary provisional government but
then of course after the
counter-revolution had kicked out again
say he spends 18 48 and 49 shuttling
between Brussels and Paris and cologne
being expelled from each one after the
other and eventually was kicked out of
France for the last time and had to get
to London yeah you see a road there's an
in 1848 just before the revolution
started pure coincidence I don't think
they started because of that the
Bolshevik Revolution in 1917 in Russia
what what did this have to do with that
anything huh well I suppose you could
reasonably say it had something to do
with it in the sense that the key
figures in the Bolshevik Revolution
Lenin and the rest of them obviously had
read it I mean they'd grown up on it so
yes I mean the the Russian Communist
Party was founded and led by people who
certainly had read the communist
manifesto and had read capital and had
read quite a few of the other books the
argument is whether they had read it
correctly or indeed whether they'd
missed something or whether they had
willfully misread parts of it let me ask
you about Das Kapital what year did he
write that what he was writing it from
based of his life he I mean it finally
the first volume came out in German in
1867 but another 20 years after the
Commish benefit but he was working on
his off and on for um most of those 20
years I mean the evening before the
Communist Manifesto in the mid 1840s
when he first met angles angles came to
Paris and stopped off where Marx was
living at the time met Marx and they had
a drink in a cafe and it
and into several drinks I like then went
back to Marc's his apartment has stayed
there for ten days let me start because
we should ask you about this man
Friedrich Engels we're at war again did
he meeting they miss in Paris and as I
say they had this conversation that
ended up lasting for 10 days what was
meant to be a drink in a cafe and at the
end of that it's very frustrating then
that there was never much of a detailed
account of this after all rather
important meeting and the only thing
angles ever wrote about it was while I
met Marx in Paris we talked for 10 days
at the end of that it became clear that
we were pretty much in complete
agreement on most things and we would
work together from then on that's all he
said and there's no account of what went
on in these 10 days just that at the end
of it they decided they got on so well
and they were in such agreement that
they would be collaborators where a mr.
angles from he was from place called
Wuppertal he was some in World War II in
Germany oh yeah they were both German he
was some the son of a fairly wealthy
textile man his father angle senior
owned cotton factories in Lancashire and
we started in Germany but he then
expanded into Lancashire which was at
the time the center of the cotton trade
so he ran textile firm in Germany but
also had this outpost in Manchester with
his partners at a German family called
Hermann and Engels junior Friedrich
Engels Marx his friend when Marx ended
up in England in exile he summoned
Engels to join him which he did then it
became clear that Marx couldn't survive
he had no money angles then volunteered
to go to Manchester and join the family
firm because his father had been very
keen to for him to work in this so the
father was very pleased oh my boy
following my example great you get a
Manchester and on the factory there
which Engels did for 20 years but his
only reason for doing that was to make
enough money to subsidize Marx I mean
not that he didn't enjoy it he had quite
a good time with Manchester he behaved
like a local captain of industry he kept
several horses and went out fox hunting
and had large wine cellar and so on but
nevertheless it was all for a rather
different cause which certainly his
business associates wouldn't have known
that
he was busily corresponding every day
with Marx sending him money but also
sending him ideas arguing about ideas
even ghosts writing for him I mean quite
often if Marx was too ill or too
distracted to write some bit of
journalism he had to do particularly
when he was writing his columns in the
New York Tribune and they Tribune angles
would just act as ghostwriter
if the Tribune got in touch and said to
Marx right we want a piece on military
strategy or something or other Marx
wasn't very good on that whereas Engels
was mad on military matters so he would
write it so Marx would send it in under
his name so much so much so that the
editors in New York thought they spent
Marx he's an absolute genius Ferris
generals have sent us fan letters saying
your correspondent in England is
brilliant on matters of military
strategy little guessing that it was old
Engels all wrong any way of knowing how
much money and Karl Marx's life he got
from Friedrich English angles you can't
get a definite exact total because some
letters have gone missing and also they
may well have been occasions where
Engels was handing over money in person
and no record was kept but certainly for
some periods you can go through their
correspondence and in the letter
angles will say I enclose five pounds I
enclose one pounds one pound and it was
usually well well over 100 pounds a year
which was quite a decent sum in those
days and then when Engels in the in the
late 1860's about 1869 70 angles sold
his stake in the family business and
retards down to London at long last
after 20 years in Manchester to vini
remarks and he set Marx up with the kind
of pension of three hundred and fifty
pounds a year which was a very decent
salary in those days I mean that was you
know what a comfortably off middle-class
family would live on very comfortably
off and Marx was then got this annuity
thanks to Engels of 350 pounds a year
for the rest of his life very nice - why
did he do it
why did angles do it yeah well because
he believed in Marx and he well he would
sometimes say and rise that when you
meet genius you have to acknowledges and
he clearly believed Marx was some kind
of genius or their angles himself very
intelligent man in many ways better than
Marx certainly more proficient
writing more efficient as well he
actually could meet his deadlines and
get his pieces finished on time even
though he was running a business as well
full time whereas Marx was a great
procrastinator this is why capital took
so many years to write because he would
get on with it and then by the time he
got near what he thought was the end he
would decide that the beginning was no
good he would start all over again so
discard the first half of the manuscript
by the time he'd read a map from scratch
the second half would be no good and so
I mean he would never have finished it
at all if angles hadn't kept bullying
him saying that you've just got a break
off and send it to the printers and be
done with it so angles was every
complimented marks very well I think in
terms of organization but also as a
great intellectual partner of his and
Bengals although very bright and quite
interesting nevertheless realized that
he was always going to be second fiddle
because he thought he detected in March
they marks a genuinely original mind
which must be encouraged and nurtured
and he obviously decided it was his
life's duty to subsidize this man but
also act as a kind of intellectual
companion for him because Marx was
rather lonely intellectually for long
periods because he fell out with so many
of his comrades that jangles was almost
the only person who consistently could
argue through ideas with him let me read
this is not fun to read and it won't be
fun to hear but I want to read this just
because it it it's obviously you read
things like this throughout the whole
book I want you to explain it 200 page
287 you're talking about the manuscript
of capital the demands of his family
talking about Karl Marx the demands of
his family and creditors and of course
those blossoming boils on his bum which
were more prolific than ever he hacked
away at them with a cutthroat razor
watching with vicious satisfaction as
the bad blood spurted over the carpet
what is this lawyer he's like ah not a
pretty sight I mean how much of that did
you find in his life a loss what what
explain what that is he was a pretty ill
man one way or another he was prey to
all sorts of things and a lot of it was
just to do with his way of life he had
an incredibly bad diet and an unhealthy
lifestyle I mean he drank heavily he
changed smoked really foul cheap cigars
he would sit up half
the night's working and then lie down in
the morning and doze for a couple of
hours on a sofa and then return to work
he going partly he didn't have any money
so he couldn't afford to live that well
but even when he did have money I mean
he tended to not bother much about his
diet and of course you know in general
terms of Hygiene he scarcely ever washed
as I suppose a lot of people didn't in
those days I mean in when they were
living in their rooms and so how their
upstairs rooms if they wanted to get any
water to wash with you would have to go
all the way down to the basement with a
bucket finish up and go back upstairs so
on the whole not exactly much the way a
bath thing in a showering went on and
that combined with perhaps some sort of
predisposition to illness anyway but
mainly I think the condition of his life
meant that he had boils he got chest
pains
he had pleurisy at one time or another
he would get all sorts of things
endless colds and coughs really bad
bronchial troubles and especially these
wretched boils were the bane of his life
just as he got rid of one lot they would
reappear somewhere else on his body I
mean when he was finishing capital the
last few pages the manuscript he had to
write it standing up because it was too
painful to sit down and he stood there
writing his last few pages and then
wrote a letter to angles he somehow held
the bourgeoisie personally responsible
for his boils and he said those
bourgeoisie will remember like
carbuncles for the rest of their life
what's mine they are but my book full
guarantee that they remote they never
forget my boils I don't know quite why
he thought it was their fault except
that they kept him in this condition to
poverty therefore he couldn't afford to
eat properly I don't know why he blamed
them for his general unhealthiness
though since a lot of it was more to do
with his smoking and drinking habits I
think you caught a Russian police spy as
saying the following
he leads the existence of a real
bohemian intellectual washing grooming
and changing his Lennon are things he
does rarely and he likes to get drunk
though he is often idle for days on end
he will work day and night with tireless
endurance when he has a great deal of
work to do
he has no fixed times for going to sleep
or waking up he often stays up all night
and then lies down fully clothed on the
sofa on the sofa at midday and sleeps
till evening untroubled by
comings and goings of the whole world
you think you would have liked to be
around him I wouldn't have liked to live
with him I must say I would very much
like to have had a drink with him or two
in his case I think he well how could
one not and especially if I was having
written his biography of course I would
love to meet him and I would certainly
like to go out on perhaps not on a pub
crawl with him which he did tend to go
in for sometimes drinking a pint of beer
in every pub in one stretch of road and
since there were 18 pubs by the time he
got to the end he tended to be a bit
boisterous and I'm start throwing stones
at the lamp posts and things maybe that
would have been the point at which I
made my excuses and left I certainly
wouldn't have wanted to live with him of
his domestic arrangements were just a
nightmare and I suspect I would have
fallen out with him because most people
did even people who had been quite close
collaborators sooner or later tended to
fall foul of him because of some
perceived shortcomings in them or
because he felt that they had taken a
wrong turning and he was pretty brutal
in argument and in his assessments of
his fellow socialists I mean it's some
long tradition in the left-wing movement
that people on the left a far more
vicious towards their supposed comrades
and they are towards the supposed common
enemy
then as now over the whole history of
the left is a history of splits and
splinter movements and internecine
warfare of every possible kind and Marx
said they went in for a lot of that
because there were so many different
varieties of socialist and all in one
way or another
failed to come up to what he regarded as
his standards chapter one here in the
Communist Manifesto the version that I
have from 1964 bourgeois and/or
bourgeoisie and and proletarians what is
a bourgeois
well I suppose the synonym usually is
middle class but more specifically when
he writes about the bourgeoisie and
especially in the Communist Manifesto
there he is writing about it has a
revolutionary force the Communist
Manifesto one thing that sometimes
surprises people is how complimentary he
is about the bourgeoisie he pays
tremendous tribute to them it's kind of
lyrical him in parts to the achievements
of the bourgeoisie and the Industrial
Revolution the Industrial class if you
like
just realizing class because the
bourgeoisie had basically toppled the
old feudal era Socratic order therefore
he regarded them and says and Commodus
manifested that they played a
tremendously progressive role in the
19th century in bringing about a
bourgeois democracy as well as border
our capitalism under this was a vast
improvement on the old landed feudal
system but of course in the Marxian view
although he pays them this great tribute
and said I mean he's genuine he says and
means it that their technological
innovations are marvels and miracles and
worthy of great admiration but this is
merely the transitional stage before the
next class down I mean the argument he
has is that throughout history the the
supreme class is then threatened by the
class immediately below it and as that
class gains more economic power so it
takes over political power as has been
shown you know bit by bit over the years
with kings and aristocrats and clergy
and feudal Nobles and ultimately by the
bourgeoisie and so he then extrapolated
from that to say well the next thing
that will happen is that the rising
proletariat as it becomes more
economically important will naturally
carry out the same sort of function
towards the bourgeoisie as the
bourgeoisie did towards the aristocracy
and the previous ruling class that was
where I think come you could reasonably
say he failed to spot one or two points
mostly the enduring resilience of
emotionally and just how
well-established it could become by
colonizing other classes in a way that
perhaps hadn't happened before that you
would have him in Engels somewhere does
writes that in Britain which drove the
Mad Britain because it was the rock on
which all these revolutionary waves
broke in vain because Britain was so
utterly unrealistic he says in Britain
they have not only of a bourgeois
bourgeoisie but they have a bourgeois
aristocracy and a bourgeois proletariat
now the whole country is just becoming
bourgeois which is true and we now even
have a bourgeois monarchy in England
where you have Prince Charles and well
Prince William and Harry going around in
baseball caps and spending their
holidays at Euro Disney and going to eat
in McDonald's so we do I'm afraid so we
have borne out what Engels suggested
might well happen to find the
proletariat well the proletariat
certainly in Marxist terms was the
industrial proletariat
it was the new class created by the
Industrial Revolution and Marx's point
about the proletariat was that before
the Industrial Revolution you know you
had all sorts of disparate people over
the country who were working in one way
or another on the land or whatever but
were isolated and the Industrial
Revolution by creating by bringing
people into the cities and creating
these large factories and so forth had
brought together these people and so
according to his account fits the
bourgeoisie who created this Industrial
Revolution had actually dug its own
grave because it had facilitated the
means whereby the proletariat could
actually organize collectively because
there were all these people now working
together in large factories and
industries and it was inevitable that
they would then combine and start
asserting their power so that was his
line of approaches to complete the
circle did your friend Ike who drives
the Amtrak trains the engineer did he
consider himself to be a member the
proletariat I should think he does yes
he certainly would call himself a worker
yes as he is in the Communist Manifesto
there are 10 points as you know that he
suggests that all countries most
countries would would live under if they
lived under the Communist Manifesto and
as one name some of them and ask you to
expand on one abolition of property in
land and application of all rents of
land to public purposes to a heavy
progressive or graduated income tax
three abolition of all right of
inheritance for confiscation of the
property of all immigrants and rebels 5
centralization of credit in the hands of
the state by means of a National Bank
with State Capitol annex and an
exclusive monopoly so far as we read
that any country in the world have this
today uh looks like Oh No Cuba possibly
China not even in China I think no six
centralization of the means of
communication and transport in the hands
of the state well that actually I'm to a
certain degree has come false in lots of
places where you have a state transport
system extension of factories and
instruments of production
owned by the state they're bringing into
cultivation of wastelands and the
improvement of the soil generally in
accordance with a common plan at seven
eight equal liability of all to labor
establishment of industrial armies
especially for agriculture happen
anywhere and duster loam is perhaps lost
I mean in the as you look back I mean if
he were here today well this yes I mean
I think what do you think how did this
patter this fair in history well I think
one thing you do have says that that is
as it says in the title a manifesto it
is a pamphlet a manifesto written very
quickly at a specific point in history
at the beginning of 1848 when he thought
upheavals were coming he dashed it off
in a few days and wrote it as a
manifesto and I mean I think you don't
expect manifestos necessarily to hold up
indefinitely I mean I think it's amazing
is still in print after 150 years most
manifestos have forgotten about a year
after they're published so then and
certainly not obeyed by the people who
were elected on those manifestos so I
think you have to look at this as I mean
he didn't write it as a kind of a
message for all time and he'd changed
his ideas and developed his ideas a lot
after that he this was something he
dashed off at that time this was his
immediate ten point plan he adapted that
in many many ways over subsequent years
so there were endless arguments about
the precise nature of central banks for
example than what should be done with
agricultural rents and the
nationalization of land and also there
was far more and his later work also
about democratization and about the
democratic nature this thing and
actually if you look for example that
some of his later documents which set
out lists of demands I mean rod like the
English Chartists which was the
Socialist Movement inning that the Marx
got quite involved with a lot of the
demands there and in the plans or
manifesto as the mark subsequently
issued and now common practice among
social democratic governments and even
not very social democratic governments
like um universal franchise for well in
that and in fact in his case for men
over the age of 21 whereas some I don't
think they've even thought about women
getting the vote and
paying parliamentarians elected
politicians of salary so that
working-class people wouldn't be
excluded from it because they didn't
have the money of course he hadn't quite
anticipated how much it would cost to
run an American presidential campaign
the president may get a salary but it
doesn't mean that any old person with no
money can stand and be elected but
nevertheless you know it was in his view
a progressive thing trained for it
haven't paid politicians so that you you
wouldn't need a private income to do it
and they're awful you know very moderate
demands suggesting that there should be
some sort of state education service
state welfare benefits for people who
have fallen through the net and are
unable to live otherwise or unable to
work and awful lot of these things are
now hardly seem very revolutionary
they've been adopted in the twentieth
century by an awful lot of firm
governments that certainly wouldn't call
themselves marxist in any shape or form
including in Britain and France and
Germany and elsewhere in the back of
your book and a little bio under your
picture it says Frances Wayne is a
British journalist and broadcaster who
was named columnist of the year in 1997
for his Wiens world page which appears
weekly in The Guardian newspaper in
London
does it still appear there oh yes yes
except this week I'm not there to do it
but what do you write about most the
time pretty well everything it's mostly
politics but by no means all politics
some anything that occurs to be rarely
it's sort of half muckraking and
crusading and half amusing I hope it's I
mean it's not just pure punditry I mean
I do actually try to give some
information as well I mean I regard
journalism as being the them the
informing of the reader so it's not just
one of those some holding fourth type
columns some saying well isn't it
disgraceful such such I do also try to
find things out and report them but I
try to do it in a vaguely entertaining
way and then you're right he lives amid
the rural idiocy
that's what Marx thought of the
countryside yes of East Anglia with his
lover several children and a large
menagerie of animals now I know those
things don't get in there without
approval the author I assume I see him
not slow that line now why would you
write what's that mean he lives amid the
rural idiocy of with his
her several children and a large
menagerie around well the rural idiocy
if it was just a joke because Marx was
pretty rude about the countryside regard
it as place where primitives lived he
was very much a metropolitan man had the
Metropolitan prejudice against the
countryside which I believe persists to
this day possibly even in Washington
some parts of Washington DC let alone
New York and and I suppose I do live in
the countryside and he's staying there
whenever I go to London some of my
friends who had devoted Londoners will
poke fun at me and say what would Marx
make of you living out in the sticks
there with your Pig and your chickens
and your ducks call yourself a
sophisticate look at you you're a yokel
so I just put that ink as marks but of
regard it is real idiocy and the
business about the lover and the
children is just true I mean number is
one of there's some problems of
terminology since we're not married I
can't recall her my wife at some part
that makes it sound as if she might be
the business part there are some kind
how long you been with her very good
question since the beginning of 1993 so
someone of it years and I made children
dear
well boy we have five children living
with us altogether she has three older
children which she brought up
single-handedly by a previous marriage
and her previous husband left her when
the youngest was one year old so she
brought them up alone and they're now
very big then our 21 and 19 and 17 and
then we have two more children who are
five and three Bertie and Archie and so
we have quite a houseful three teenagers
and two toddlers and you dedicate the
book to four Julia is that that is up
there it is Julia Jones now how did you
go about writing this but biography or
researching it and how many of these
what was the last time there was a full
biography of Karl Marx well in the very
early 70s I think about 1971 was the
last one which was David McClelland and
that was one in about 1969 by Michael
Robert Payne those are the only other
two ones that I'm aware of in say the
last 40 years or 50 years really I mean
there have been remarkably few and as I
say none really since 1971 since the
MacLennan book and it seemed to me that
from the Vantage
bunch of of now it was perhaps easier to
to see what was worth retrieving from
Marx and to strip away an awful lot of
the 20th century layers with which he
become he or his reputation of becoming
crusted and also I very much wanted to
write a life of Marx aimed at if you
like the intelligent general reader
because most books on Marx tend to be
written by academics or zealots or both
for an audience of academics or zealots
or both so they assume a great deal of
not prior knowledge they write it most
in jargon and also they're not that
interested in the man and the life they
want to skip through that as quickly as
possible so they can have five hundred
pages on arguments about the labor
theory of value or something really sexy
like that and I want I had a feeling
that there were lots of people who might
surprise themselves by actually becoming
quite interested if they were given an
accessible and readable life of Marx
which didn't assume any previous
knowledge just as I mean people read
biographies of other Victorian sages of
various kinds whether it's Dickens or
Carlyle or whoever without necessarily
being great experts on the work and I
thought well maybe they could give Marx
a try I'm how many places did you travel
to see where Marx had either lived or
worked well luckily not that many my
task has made a lot easier by the fact
that most of Marx's papers are in
Amsterdam which is an accident of
history when Marx died they passed two
angles when he died Marx his daughter
Eleanor and this dreadful evening her
lover took over and they started sorting
them out then when they died the papers
were given to the German Social
Democratic Party which in those days was
a much more left-wing party than its
that it is now but then in the 1930s
when the Nazis came to power the German
Social Democrats panicked and thought
we've got to get these out of the
country you know the Nazis have already
burned them all so they packed them off
to Amsterdam to an institute there
called the Institute for social history
where they remained to this day the
Germans never asked them back so and
they were all sweetly had this idea that
of course the Dutch would be safe
because the Nazis would never invade
Holland needless to say the Nazis did
invade Holland but apparently didn't
notice or didn't care that all Marx his
manuscripts and letters were hidden away
there so there they are these days it
makes
very easy if you're researching box an
awful lot of it can be done in Amsterdam
go to the Institute of social history
and you fill in your slip and there come
up all these wonderful files you know
you could actually get his old laundry
lists practically or scraps of paper on
which he wrote little messages to
himself he kept everything I mean given
the chaos of his domestic arrangements
it's quite surprising and impressive
that's so much survived I think it's
partly because he was incapable of
throwing anything away you haven't you
have 12 chapters and I just want to read
and we don't have much time so I need a
very quick reaction to but the titles of
these chapters for instance the little
wild boar what was that that's Chapter
two well that was what Jenny Marx's
future wife called him when they were
first engaged she wrote in these love
letters when he was away in Bonn and
Cologne in places and she tended to
refer to him as my little wild boar
chapter 3 the grass-eating king well
that's to do with a story that Heinrich
Heine told as a kind of warning Tamar
Heine the great German poet was a friend
of marks but was rather wary of marks
his some politics and told this sort of
parable of a king who ended up reducing
himself the level of cattle and eating
grass chapter 4 the mouse in the Attic
that was a book that Marx wrote called
the German ideology and when he had
finished it he couldn't find a publisher
and so as he said he put it away in in
the attic and consigned it to the
knowing criticism of the mice and if you
look at the manuscript today it does
actually have little nibbles around the
edges as if it really was liberally
eaten by the mice chapter 5 the
frightful Hobgoblin well that's the
Communist Manifesto I mean the first
line of the comment is manifesto which
is quite famous is a specter is stalking
Europe the spectre of communism but the
very first English translation in 1850
which appeared in a newspaper called the
red Republican done by a vice Chartist
woman started a frightful Hobgoblin is
stalking arif but I never caught on
unfortunately the frightful hog goblin
number six they Megalosaurus to way
pronounce it the Megalosaurus yes that's
a line from Dickens's novel Bleak House
the very opening scene there he has this
wonderful picture of London
in the fog and the mud and the wet and
everything and he says you know so much
for guns so much appearing that it would
not be a wonder if a Megalosaurus was
seen walking along home and he'll
because it seemed or was primeval
swamp like nature of London and this is
the London to which Marx moved in 18-49
the London of Dickens and the London of
T super fogs and mud and chaos and in
which he might find a Megalosaurus never
staring the hungry wolves well as his
creditors as I say he was always short
of money and the butcher the baker the
candlestick maker would say but not
going to supply with any more until he
pay our bills and bailiffs were banging
at his door sometimes the bailiffs would
come round and say you're three months
behind with your rent we've got to see
your husband mrs. marks and she say oh
no afraid he's gone away on business for
a few days and in fact he would be
upstairs hiding under his desk until the
bailiffs are gone and he referred to his
creditors as the hungry wolves chapter 7
is chapter 8 was the hero on horseback
well that's Mark's approach marks his
attitude to people like LaSalle
Ferdinand Lassalle the German socialist
who regarded himself as the hero who
would leave the German masses into
revolution and Marx is very against this
of the great man view of history the
idea that you needed a Napoleonic figure
to lead the workers to their salvation
he said no the workers must lead
themselves to their salvation if you put
your trust in heroes on horseback or
princes even socialist princes then
you're lost the ninth chapter is the
Bulldogs and the hyena that is a very
obscure reference the Bulldogs are John
Bull the British bulldog and the hyena
is an Austrian monster called general
Heino a torturer who came to London on
holiday and was attacked by the English
workers and chased through London and
d-bags and this caused great amazement
because it wasn't thought that the
English workers had any sense of
international solidarity or
internationalism number 10 is the shaggy
dog that's that's capital that's my
reading of des capital which is I
suggest not a straight economic treatise
but a shaggy dog story almost more like
a novel in the tradition of tristram
shandy or a satyr like Gulliver's
Travels and that if you read it as that
a lot of the oddities in it become much
clearer because you realise they're
entirely deliberate number L
the rogue elephant that is bakunin the
enormous Russian anarchists with whom
Marx had this great showdown and he was
often referred to as an elephant just
because of his great size the Russian
elephant when did he live and what
impact did he ever on Karl Marx bakunin
yes well he his main impact on Karl Marx
was to annoy him intensely and provoke
this great fight which basically brought
about the end of the International
workingmen's association Bakunin and
Marx although they had been friendly
early on then had this some duel to the
death and Marx won but at the price of
killing off the International which he
helped to create chapter 12 the last
chapter the shaven porcupine well that's
Marx himself a year before he died in
his last couple of years he was pretty
ill all the time and went round spa
towns and resorts in search of ozone and
cures and things and one of these trips
the year before he died was to Algiers
and from there and that photo you have
there is the very last picture taken of
him in 1882 being rather genial and
father Christmasy the very day after he
took that photo in Algiers he went to a
barber shop had his beard and hair
shaved off sent a letter home saying I
have sacrificed my Mane on the altar of
my fleece on the altar of an Algerian
barber and it was almost a sort of
Samson like symbolic gesture of
renouncing his powers and the mitting
that he had really abandoned any hope of
doing any more work so he came home
clean shaven and bald but he made sure
that no one ever saw him like that or
remembered him like that rather because
he'd had this last picture taken which
is the one you showed there so we never
saw Marx clean-shaven a bald face in
1875 a picture of him there's another
one very shaggy looking figure I mean he
would lose a lot of his sort of iconic
resonance I think I mean that gravestone
and I get cemetery if he didn't have the
beard and the hair he would have a very
different effect on people I think he
knew the impact it had he said he used
it he played up to being a sort of Old
Testament prophet or Greek godlike
figure he'd he actually thought he
looked like Jupiter because a friend had
a bust of Jupiter and said it looks just
like you that beard and he's very proud
of this he would stand next to it saying
or do you think we look alike what was
your biggest surprise in this book
goodness gracious
it was full of surprises in a way just
the little incidental human details of
marks certainly to those who've been
brought up upon him as his grim
forbidding figure are a constant
surprise though I mean to me they became
less of a surprise because I knew more
about him I suppose but just to know all
the business of his going off and
getting drunk and playing chess sitting
up all night playing chess because he
was so determined to beat his opponent
liebknecht and kept trying to work out
new systems which would allow him to win
at chess and his justice his sense of
fun actually and the family man going
walking up to Hampstead Heath in North
London on Sundays for a picnic lunch
every week and taking the children
sitting there having pickly lodged them
playing games on the heath and walking
back reciting Shakespeare to the
children and singing Negro spirituals or
old German folk songs or goodness knows
what but I think it's a side of Marx
that perhaps hasn't been much noticed
even ever postscript to Proust
questionnaire that Marcel Proust pops up
again what's this about well that was a
parlor game that was very popular at the
time called confessions which is a bit
like the Bruce questionnaire where you
have to answer various questions and
what is your favorite virtue what's your
favorite author your favorite color that
sort of thing and this is one that his
his children forced him to fill in and
his motto in there I think was de
omnibus Juba tandem everything was be
doubted we're out of time
this is the cover of the book it's
called Karl Marx a life by Frances Wien
and we thank you very much for joining
us a pleasure